ce qui a fait porter les efforts des
autorités
on est parti
super beau serrières les couleurs en
plus comble tout ça non pas ce dynamique
hop
alors à tous les détails la colline à la
mentalité qu'elle avait les doigts
théâtre ça me va bien
l'impression qu'on n'est pas assez les
enfants l'un des gelées ou de pato
télécom je demande est là si le passé
comme le demandait la tradition elle
refaire je ne voulais pas photo les
témoins je partais au télé est en fête
et intrants
c'est trop laissé pour cible par des
cons on l'a découvert pour bellaing tape
it baltique new zealand au maximum
qu'est ce qui te permet aux thèses a
tout eu lieu
cette light
c'est beau ça non la rivalité pas mal du
tout voir ouais ouais
omer donc donné découvre enfin bon on le
voit le train alors voilà on la voit
toujours un mais bon eux
allez hop un autre et welsh atteint les
poutres une robuste
cole
alors comment cet arrêt
pas plus sauf pas puissant qui pas plus
nord sauvage d'accrocher la cime
accroche-toi dans l'ombre enfin si toi
tout arrêter la cps est bon mais c'est
quoi